imagine two people who share an
important secret have to split up this
requires them to communicate private
information from a distance however an
eavesdropper named Eve also wants this
information and has the ability to
intercept their messages so Alice
decides to communicate using letters
written in some kind of secret code the
following analogy is helpful first Alice
locks her message in a box using a lock
that only her and Bob know the
combination to this is known as
encryption then the locked message is
sent to Bob when Bob receives the Box he
opens it using the code they shared in
advance this is called decryption
cryptography begins when we abandoned
physical locks and use ciphers instead
think of them as virtual locks ciphers
allow Alice and Bob to scramble and D
scramble their messages so that they
would appear meaningless if Eve
intercepted them cryptography has been
around for thousands of years it has
decided Wars and is at the heart of the
worldwide communication network today
the fascinating story of cryptography
requires us to understand two very old
ideas related to number theory and
probability theory
you